hello thank you for joining us my name
is fen Buckland and I'm director of
scientific affairs at banana genomics
I'm excited to talk to you about our
genome imaging solution for
high-throughput detection of structural
variation in cancer and genetic disease
well focus on cancer clear so when we're
talking about structural variation we're
talking about these large rearrangements
in the genome that can occur really all
throughout and if you're a scientist
who's keeping up with the the high-tech
methods in longwood sequencing and all
that it may be a surprise to you that
the standards of structural variation
detection in a clinical setting is still
standard cytogenetics and what happens
there is really a 50-year old method
where cytogeneticist use a microscope to
look at intact molecules of DNA and
visualize the patterns on these
molecules and by looking at changing
these patterns they detect structural
variation so when NGS came around there
was this idea that if we could simply
sequence all the letters in the genome
we would be able to see these structural
variations just as well but that hasn't
actually worked out that way at all
mostly because these NGS researchers
didn't come with a microscope they came
with its with a blender and this may
seem silly but I've challenged you to
find to tell me how many pieces of
strawberry were in this blender and
where they were after I turned this
machine on but that is exactly what you
do when you run an ng as experiments the
first step is that you take your
beautiful intact genome and you shred it
into tiny little pieces and then you try
to glue these pieces back together
algorithmically to get an idea of what
that genome looks like now imagine what
would happen if you could just look at
this structure without shredding it
first makes a lot more sense and that is
one of the issues but one of the
complications with next-generation
sequencing also is that the genome is
just really highly repetitive it's just
about a third of the genome consisting
of unique sequences and 2/3 consisting
of repeats and how all but one of these
repeats that are mentioned here in this
slide for each of them each unit on
their own is already longer than the
standard Reath length of off Salem
sequencing longer than 250 base pairs so
now imagine making sense of long tandem
arrays of these repeats with only 100 or
150 base pairs at a time it's just not
possible and now you can say I don't
care about these repeats but a lot of
the structural variants in the genome
are actually flanked by these it's
because they're caused by the repeats
recombining through something like non
allylic homologous recombination or
incorrect repair and and so if you're
blind to these repeats in the genome
you're often also blind by the
structural variants that are flanked by
them and that's why right now the
standard of care still for a
cytogeneticist to look at these intact
DNA molecules with a microscope and
that's exactly what by nano genomics
does to look at the genome except for
we're adding a nano channel array these
are hundreds of thousands of nano
channels in parallel where we can
linearize these DNA molecules massive
mega base size molecules and image
patterns and these molecules that we
place on there in an enzymatic reaction
so think about karyotyping but with a
500 thousand times with a limited a
thousand times higher resolution 500
thousand of these labels in the entire
treatment our microscope is called
sapphire and it automates the imaging of
these DNA molecules now by a nano
produces the instrument the sapphire
instrument but we also have our chips
that linearize the DNA we have kids for
DNA extraction and labeling and I'll
tell you in a second how that works and
then we have our own analysis tools as
well through by nano axis our software
now I want to get to cancer and how our
technology plays a role in cancer
research or diagnostics but let me start
by telling you how it all works the
first step if you want to image mega
base size molecules is to get two mega
base size molecules
that's important because every single
every standard DNA isolation method
whether it uses spin columns or whether
it uses magnetic beads or whether you
simply precipitate the DNA
we'll just shear that DNA to ripped that
DNA apart by the mechanical forces
exerted on them and that's why we
developed a protocol that is very very
gentle here realize the DNA in solution
and we use a disk similar in material to
say a hydrogen column but it has a 3d
structure that allows it to hold onto
micrograms of DNA that are attached to
that this now you simply wash it and
alluded in a new tube and there's no
mechanical forces there's no grinding
there's no spinning and so the DNA that
comes out is mega basis in length the
protocol is fast it just takes a few
hours were automating that right now it
works on fresh or frozen blood we don't
need more than 650 microliters of fresh
or frozen blood we can work with the
cultured cells a million two million and
a half is ideal or we can work with
biopsies cancer biopsies for example for
as low as 10 milligrams keep in mind
that we cannot work with FFPE treated
samples because the DNA is simply to
fragment or to damaged after that
however we have other stabilization
liquid similar to a formalin where you
could when you take a biopsy simply put
the material in that solution for up to
a week before you freeze it now if you
look at this here you get an idea of
what other DNA isolation kits look like
they give you for a long read sequencing
it shows here 20 to 30 KB now if you
place that on that graph on the left
here would by nano you see that that's
all the way in the far left because our
molecules have an average length of
about 300 KB and go all the way up to
mega bases as you can see in that tail
there so the DNA that you isolate with
our prep method is just extremely long
nothing compared to other methods that
are out there a consequence of this of
course is that if you have DNA that's
already isolated on the sample it's
probably not going to work it will not
be long enough once we have four mega
base size DNA the next step is to label
a specific six base pair sequence motif
we're doing that with an enzyme and a
somatic method that we call direct label
and stain
here the enzyme will recognize that
sixth base pair sequence and attach the
floor for directly to the DNA there's no
nicking there's no breaking it's a
single enzymatic reaction and we use a
single six base pair sequence motif all
throughout the genome so there's no
probes involved there's no multiple
combinations of colors and labels it's
just a single label all throughout the
genome it's a six base pair sequence and
it occurs every 6 kb or so and then the
result looks like what you see on the
top left there a really a ball of
wrapped up very long DNA with labels
attached and then we linearize that DNA
we use electrophoresis to pull the DNA
into nano channels and these nano
channels are so narrow that a single
molecule that's in that channel is
uniformly stretched and because of that
uniform stretch because it cannot coil
up we get all the information that we
need just by taking a picture and a
picture tells us the distance between
these labels and we can convert that
into base pairs the array locals
hundreds of thousands of these channels
and you can see in this image below that
every vertical line that you see is a
molecule that's sitting in one of these
channels shown above the blue signal is
the backbone of the DNA molecule that it
sustains with an intercalating dye and
then in green you see that label that we
attached to the DNA all throughout the
genome this is what it really looks like
when the DNA moves through these fillers
it unwinds and goes into the nano
channels and then linearizes that now
the instrument will cycle molecules
enter the channels image then new
molecules and image them over and over
again and that allows us to run six
human genomes for 24 hours or 42 samples
per week later this year we will
increase that through an upgrade to the
instrument software to nine human
genomes
per week sorry per day nine human
genomes per day so more than 60 per week
or you can also run these flow cells
simply longer and collect more data on
that so each of the chips have three
flow cells each flow cell
can collect 400x of coverage of a sample
we say 48 hours in reality it's a lot
faster than that so what this means is
that you can collect a whole lot of data
on complex cancer genomes and I'll show
you later what you can do with that
amount of data also keep in mind that
the cost per sample is just about 500
dollars including the chips and the
labeling reaction so even if you collect
400 X if you run the chip longer there's
no larger expense once we collect these
images on all of these nano channels
over and over again our software will
collect will extract the digital
information of these molecules and then
we perform a de novo assembly of the
genome meaning that we will align every
G every molecule that we imaged with
every molecule that we imaged all
through our genome and we find overlap
build an overlap graph like you see here
and an out of that at the bottom of
consensus genome map and that consensus
mapper represents the average spacing of
each of the labels that we see all
throughout eugenia our software does
this ANOVA
meaning that it's not reference guided
and that means that it would actually
know whether it's assembling a human
genome or tomato plant or a cockroach we
just built a genome that we see once the
genome is built we can then compare
these maps to each other or to a
reference in this case if the reference
is in green we will align our Maps de
novo assemble to the reference and look
for alignment and look for differences
so in this case here you see deletion
relative to the reference where the
spacing between these labels decreases
since we know the reference genome we
know where that sixth base pair sequence
motif is throughout the genome so that's
how we can convert the reference into
maps like this and do these alignments
of course all the knowledge from the
reference still comes along meaning that
we know where the genes are or the
regulatory elements are cetera so we can
detect each major type of structural
variance that way let's start with
deletions on top here you see the
reference in green your sample is
at the bottom in blue and you see to the
spacing between these two labels
decreases when that's spacing decreases
by 500 base pairs we call that
automatically genome-wide as a deletion
an insertion is similar to spacing
between two labels increases and at fact
for the base fare or more that is an
insertion we can look at repeat arrays
where you can you can see that there's a
change in the number of repeats
sometimes you have a label per repeat
like shown here sometimes it's not the
case and then we can simply measure the
flanking labels we can attack tandem
duplications you see that this pattern
here on top aligns on the left but also
on the right the yellow labels are
labeled that simply don't align we
detect enemy duplications direct or
inverted automatically at 30 KB and
above a translocations detected like
this we build a genome map in blue that
aligns for half of one chromosome for
half with another chromosome or a
different part of the same chromosome we
detect these genome why it's
automatically and the same is true for
inversions where we simply look for a
pattern that's flipped around
genome-wide again a 30 KB and inversions
are really hard to detect with
sequencing based methods were very good
at that
so here again you see that minimum sizes
for deletions and insertions as slow as
500 base pairs and that's because we're
just looking at the spacing between
these labels and then for duplications
translocations and inversions we need at
least 30 or 50 KB and that is because
we're actually looking at complex
patterns and how these patterns are
changed now when you first analyze a
genome and you open our browser our by
nano axis you will see a circus plot
like this where each of the chromosomes
are shown in the concentric circle and
the different type of structural
variants are present there as dots and
in the purple lines in the middle are
translocations between each of these
chromosomes that are shown so if you
just click on any of these events then
you zoom in straight to the map where
you can see the de novo map aligning to
different chromosomes or kids of dis
translocation
you can even show the molecules that
were in the gyre system that's
translocation calls but on top of that
all of these structural variation calls
will be filtered to a control database
so you can just filter out only the
somatic events or the rare events that
are not present in a control population
and annotate it and it can be exported
as a standard VCF file I want to walk
you through one example step-by-step so
you get an idea of how that technology
really works so we spoke with researcher
than the Anderson who have been working
on a family where four children have the
same rare very rare one-in-a-million
type of occurrence cancer and the family
have been studied by Andy Anderson for
decades with no results here we're
looking at a small part of the genome
where we imaged some molecules and if
you look at these molecules you see some
patterns on there so we build a
consensus genome map that represents the
average spacing of these labels detected
on all of these molecules when we align
that to hg19 or another reference genome
of your choice you see that there's
perfect alignment on the left
something's going on on the right half
we also assemble the wild-type allele of
course is a diploid organism and so we
expect two alleles and that one aligns
perfectly with the reference now what's
going on here is that there's a 38 KB
segment that is present in sixth annum
duplications is not present in controls
that do not have this tumor so this is a
clear netic predisposition and what's
interesting here is that this gene the
large gene on the left is known to be
mutated and is in the pathway that is
involved in this cancer so what's
interesting is that we we are so certain
that that structural variant is really
there because we're single molecules
that span the entire 230 KB of that
repeats the fact that these molecules
exist means that that structural variant
is really there this is not Germans
algorithmically by chopping up the old
genome and trying to calculate how many
reads you're expecting or something like
that no we see a single molecule and
that molecule has six times the 38 KB of
pattern on there
so structural variants are observed
directly on single molecules and not not
the juice algorithmically recently two
studies came out that compared our
structural variation calls against some
other technologies one here of the
thousand genomes project looked at 154
human samples from 26 different ethnic
groups and compared them against
compared to by a nano data against data
generated by Lumina sequencing by the
thousand genome project and even though
this study was done years ago on our old
instrument with an older labeling
chemistry that was much less sensitive
still we detected eight and a half times
more insertions and even more deletions
as well than with whole genome
sequencing and specifically insertions
are almost impossible to find with NGS
because the aligner simply don't know
where to place that extra information
and then more recently a study was
published from the human genome and
speaking searching as well where there
compared by a nano against NGS and
PacBio sequencing as well and there's a
lot of data here but if you look at this
graph here deletions on the left it
searches in the writes starting at 500
base person and going to mega bases in
the middle you see this large section of
bright blue information those are
structural variants that were only
detected by banana because we missed by
whole genome sequence they were missed
by PacBio as well so if you're not using
a technology like ours that can detect
these large structural variants you're
missing out on so much information now I
talked about repeats I'll go over this
real quick but there's an interesting
disease called FSHD which is a form of
muscular dystrophy and it's the only
known disease in the human genome that
is caused by contraction of a repeats
all the other repeats associated
disorders are expansion disorders and in
order to genotype this correctly you
need to distinguish between the
pathogenic 4q a allele and the
non-pathogenic 4qp you need to be able
to know exactly how many repeats units
there are because if the number of drops
below 10 or 8 then a transcription
factor gets turned on by changing
chromatin structure it causes the
disease now on top of all of this
there's also an identical would be done
chromosome 10 that is not involved in
the disease and you need to distinguish
between it - it's really complicated but
by Nana you just look at it and you see
how many calls there are so later this
year there's going to be most likely
three but for sure one diagnostic tests
being offered by some of our customers
for this disease clinical test and we're
really excited about them
now most expansion repeat disorders
don't have a label per repeat unit like
we showed there in that case we just
measure the flanking labels and we can
size that interval and size that
expansion this was done here at my
tongue dystrophy which is a repeat
expansion disorder just like ALS or
fragile X and now you can see here on
the right that the expanded repeat has a
much wider distribution because this
repeat becomes unstable and a tissue and
and so within a single muscle biopsy you
see a whole range of sizes and in the
last sort of genetic disease example
that I want to show you before I move on
to cancer is here a study done by Mass
General Hospital from Harvard where they
had the number of patients with a severe
congenital disorder that were map with
banana
they had a custom microarray that called
a 2.3 mega base very duplication in this
area but when we ran that with banana we
found that our copy number two in our
company number tool that just counts the
number of molecules all throughout the
genome and normalizes that found that
there was actually two separate
increases here but more importantly our
de novo assembly shown below there shows
where these duplications actually are
you see that this largest application on
the left aligns to the left and to the
right and then the second duplication on
the Rights Alliance pretty much straight
down but also an inverted ant
application to the left it overlaps with
that first section and so that large
gene there at the breakpoint is probably
interrupted there's a whole lot of
information that we provide that you
miss when you only get an array call
that tells you that there's more or less
of something even no idea where or how
that duplication
let's talk about cancer this is a very
old paper but it's uh it still really
stands out it's a few years old the
panel from the Garvan Institute in
Sydney where professor Hayes looked at
prostate cancer and analyzed the
prostate cancer sample and the blood
from the same patient using bio
nanotechnology but also using whole
genome sequence on their Illumina
extents and if you've ever tried to call
structural variants from NGS data you
know that there's a whole lot of that
algorithms that do different things that
have pros and cons some are more
sensitive some of more false positives
and so what you do is you you run a
number of different algorithms and you
look for overlap so that was what was
done here compared to Vienna and the
paper shows a large number of variants
like here this is a busy slide with I'll
walk you through it in the middle there
in orange or red you see the banana map
in red and sorted by nano map from the
blood of this patient and right below
that in blue the banana map from the
tumor of the patient and between that an
orange a 14k B somatic deletion that was
affected using art technology there's
some variants relative to the reference
shown above and below and according to
the genome browser that overlaps with a
self alignment or duplication and that
is probably why this variant was missed
entirely from the Illumina data not the
text by any algorithm however if you
look at the read pairs shown below there
in red those are repairs that validates
that the lesion call but in the context
of all the other reads those who were
missed by the aligner um and so what
they found is that using banana they
found 85 of these large insertions and
deletions so most of which affect genes
for Chumlee 9 were picked up by NGS it
almost all of them were validated by
manual inspection of these injuries and
there were a number of oncogenic driver
mutations never before seen in prostate
cancer so really great
our results right there and dr. broach
showed something similar this is right
in by our archives newspaper but it's
submitted for peer-reviewed and he
looked at 12 leukemia genomes as head of
the Penn State Institute for
personalized medicine and what they're
showing in his paper is a number of
variants again list by other methods but
found with bio Nano for example in the
case of this non-hodgkins lymphoma where
the germ lines cells were were were
mapped by growing the T lymphocytes that
are unaffected in this disease using as
germline controls they showed just a
deletion probably not relevant but in
the actual non-hodgkins lymphoma cells
there's a three mega base inversion
right next to that cuts right through
the p10 gene that breaks the kathan gene
in half and this is the this inversion
was not seen by whole genome sequence
and it was not picked up by a karyotype
or any other side to genetic method
either and b10 is a known tumor
suppressor and there are dozens of
trials going on for compounds that
rescue p10 mutants so the fact that
something like this that could really
change the outcome of the treatment was
missed by other methods except by by
nano gives you an idea of the importance
of having a method that can detect these
structural variants genome-wide in any
canister sample and so the next figure
actually builds on that because on the
left you see a list of known leukemia
driver genes that they found were
affected by multiple variants multiple
structural variants in these twelve
leukemia genomes no surprises there
really but then if you look on the right
you see a long list of known cancer
associated genes that were not before
associated with leukemia that have
recurring structural variants as well so
now these are all genes for which there
may be applicable drugs that target them
there may be prognostic value in these
genes and they've just not been checked
so if you're in a clinical setting right
now if you're if you're leukemia genome
is being analyzed they will not find
these variants but they would quit by
now and on top of that there were dozens
more of genes that were not
to be cancer associated in the first
place and yet recurrence structural
variants occur in these genes so an
enormous potential here for discovering
of biomarkers for new targets or of
jeans for prognosticators and then
lastly they found that there were a
significant enrichment of known cancer
genes nearby as feats would expect with
Vienna so those are probably regulatory
elements that were taken out by these
translocations inversions deletions or
duplications and again there's an
enormous amount of information here
that's really not been studied carefully
yet that could give you a whole new
career path if you like so dr. Burgess
paper isn't by archives he also recorded
the webinar which is available from
genome web and there's a transcription
of that as well
you can find both of those on our
website and speaking of an inversion
earlier I want to show you an unrelated
example here of a sample that was mapped
by banana and colorectal carcinoma
sample and here you see this 10 mega
Bayes inversion at the telomeric end of
chromosome 9 but interestingly the
banana map at the bottom here extends
past the reference and that is because
there's a telomere telomere fusion of 90
to 90 this is something that you cannot
detect with any other molecular method
because these tell Americans to
telomeric repeats get in the way in
banana our molecules are hundreds of
KB's in length so they anchor right
through these repetitive areas into the
rest of the chromosome and so we can
detect this telomeric fusion which which
again is almost impossible with other
methods so I spoke about our copy number
tool I spoke about our de novo assembly
tool so without copy number two and
again here we're just counting the
number of molecules all throughout the
genome and normalizing that to detect
large changes large deletions or gains
we can detect these copy number variants
larger than 250 KB down to 10% the
little fraction and that means that it's
just a fraction of the cells in your
tumor have copy number changes like this
our tool still
pick those up similar to what awakened
you really but on top of that we also
built a new rare variant pipeline and
this pipeline allows you to detect lower
little fraction structural variants with
very high sensitivity but you can't
really yeah you see you see right there
that we have ninety percent sensitivity
to detect each of these type of his fees
translocations inversions deletions
insertions and applications
down to five percent the real fraction
and again five percent the little
fraction means that if just 10% of the
cells in a tumor have a heterozygous
translocation it will still be cut up
and this is completely unbiased
there's no PCR amplification there's no
panel here we're not just looking for
events that we already know now we can
show you any translocation with any
transportation partner all throughout
the genome that's such a low annual
fraction even as low as one and a half
percent if you combine three of the flow
cells internship and it's very subtle
slide here tells you how that compares
no one else can do this no other
technology comes even close to this type
of performance not just for $500 percent
so when I tell you about a few
presentations that happened in the last
few months at various conferences these
are all unpublished results are we have
permission to show that to you but you
won't find it in a publication yet so
that's why I want to summarize them real
quick we have recordings of each of
these stocks at the banana to come by
nano genomics dot-com website under the
resources in the video section so have a
look there if you want to see more of
them but I'll I'll tell you the
conclusions real quick first dr. Levey
presented at the cancer genomics
consortium conference about a consortium
that he is running with multiple
cytogenetics groups in the United States
including the Mayo Clinic path group and
B Anderson Columbia etc
University of Washington where they are
comparing banana against standards
hydrogen no mix cytogenetics tools in
cancer so the standard of care for
leukemia is karyotype and then up to 10
or 12 fish tests now what what they did
here was run a number of Gina
I'm bio nano and compared them against
the standard such a genetic test they
show examples like this one here where
there's a large inversion x-ray on
chromosome 16 in an AML sample they
compared to by nano call against the
fish call and as you see here in banana
we get exact breakpoints in the genes
something of course that you can never
do with fish they compared our calls
against microarray calls so for example
for this CD case 66 gene deletion you
see on the left the banana map calling
219 KB at two hundred eighteen point
seven and then with array almost the
exact same 217 KB deletion what's called
so just spectacular overlap there so of
all the samples that were shown there
was one where there was absolutely no
data that made any sense was a sample
mix-up turn out with other than that
there was a complete concordance between
the banana results and the standard
stock genetics results so karyotype fish
an array and this was done in a blinded
fashion his studies on going on a much
larger sample size but for now this
result searches for exactly and then
also at the cancer genomics consortium
Rashi mechanical Shimano from MD
Anderson Cancer Center talked about MDS
myelodysplastic syndrome a precursor of
Mo and and again there she looked at a
number of samples of preliminary results
of a larger study and she found just
incredible concordance I'll show you
just one example here of where we picked
up a variant that was seen on a
karyotype the karyotype showed this
translocation here between chromosome 1
and 12 you couldn't see this complexity
here these multiple translocation events
and so when you zoom into that you see
that our software calls out the pair's
section from chromosome 1 and 12 but
also a section for chromosome 5 that was
missed by standard cytogenetics so in
several of the cases that she presented
by Anna found extra information that
went beyond what was known with standard
clinical methods I highly recommend that
you look at these presentations on our
website and the same is true for this
third study here by Alex hojin from the
Radboud University
Nijmegen in the Meadowlands they've
always been a pioneer in bringing new
methods into the clinic and so they're
doing a large validation study on 100
Leukemia samples I know some 50 samples
with constitutional cytogenetic
abnormalities and that study is far from
complete they have about 36 that they
reported on but in all of these samples
by nana detective all known clinically
reported variants and so a doctor hojin
in his conclusion really calls for a
site to genetics resolution with this
technology we hope that he's right of
course
so to summarize um how this works how we
look at cancer genomes you you see
complex genomes like like this one here
visualized in a simple view in a single
view where you see all the
translocations all the different
deletion and inversions duplication
events and there's an enormous wealth of
information so if you click on just one
single of these translocations
I'm showing there with that little arrow
you're taking through a map that shows
you the pieces of chromosome 7 and
chromosome 10 here there's an inverted
part of chromosome 7 that was
translocated to a part of chromosome 10
where there's a section followed by a
1.6 mega day's deletion then an inverted
210 KB's section then another 400 KB
deletion before the rest of the
chromosome returns so this very complex
assembly here but we have single
molecules that spend the entire array of
this fragment that I just described on
single molecules so again you cannot be
wrong but that's this type of data
there's a software partner called
shinnok's
which provides online annotation and
classification of whole genome sequence
and we've partnered with them to make
detection of structural variation much
better because they are used to working
with whole genome sequence you can take
your Illumina reads and simply upload
them to their cloud and they will call
variants and give you a clinical report
now this doesn't work for structural
variants because you just cannot call
these as fees well from that data alone
and that's why Enda so little animation
you see that if you have repairs trying
to align in this region the
do the best job they can to place them
there now in Vienna no calls a
structural variant in that region in
this case say 6kb donación
their new software can now use that
knowledge to do a better job at the line
industry so they can push them apart
like you see here and align them to that
part of the genome and now gets
sometimes single base pair resolution
brides at these breakpoints so at once
you have a validation of D call the
banana call with NGS data and you also
get much better break one precision and
so it's as if there's a new sequencing
technology now that combines the
sensitivity for structural variants that
only genome imaging or mapping solution
like ours can provide combined with
single base for accuracy of short suite
sequence finally I want to point out a
paper from one of our customers where
they use our methods to map a long range
DNA methylation and single molecule and
of course this can be interesting in
cancer as well this paper used a method
to label unmethylated recognition
sequences of an enzyme Green here and
then they used a red label to label
standard by nano structural variation
detection and so now you have the green
methylation signal that overlays in the
same molecule where you're also
detecting structural variants it allows
you to check methylation and s fees in a
single assay on single molecules and
then phase all of that about over
hundreds of KB's so now you can check
that if a promoters methylated here that
another promoter 200 K be a part is
methylated and slower about this type of
data on single molecules phasing
methylation over n bits of KP that just
doesn't exist right now so this paper is
approved principal paper but we cannot
wait to see what you do with this back
out so to summarize I think in cancer
research there's just a wide range of
applications of this long range SP
detection method we can discover new
fusion gene and help with
targeted therapy developments we can
help with biomarker discovery and find
new genetic markers for disease
progression of prognosis of therapy
response we can help culture cell lines
and and find out genome stability repair
mechanisms and and and of course our
technology can be used to look for
target effects in Chris branch in the
continuing studies etc we have results
in all them I would highly recommend
that you visit our website as I
mentioned there's videos under resources
but also click on the line all the way
at the right which is combine and oh you
and that is our blog and you can see
papers discussed you can find the latest
news you can see video recordings from
presentations from our customers at
various conferences and speaking of
conferences the day before ASHG Houston
in a few days there's a symposium
clinical research symposium where we'll
have speakers the entire day looking at
genetic disease using biotechnology some
incredible presentations are coming I
look forward to those and then at a
sheet self we also have a workshop on
Thursday you don't want to miss that
there just be some big announcements
yeah so to summarize our technology
allows for unparalleled SP detection we
can find structural variants that are
missed in with other technologies all
throughout the genome even in
heterogeneous cancer samples our answers
are confident we have extremely low
false positive rates and there's a high
correlation with standard clinical
methods we have a comprehensive solution
where you can go from your blood sample
to day down to an updated structural
variance calls in just four days or so
and with that I like to finish and uh
and thank you for your time and we're
happy to take any questions